the other thing that I think is so
interesting we've all Rave about the
stunts we all know the stunts we all
know there's going to be running we know
there's going to be action-packed but I
think that I think people don't
understand that Tom in addition to
stunts really focuses on characters
doesn't he I think something that I love
and something that we don't it's not
about talking about we know he does the
stunts but to be on set and have this
scene that is explosive and dynamic and
have Tom at a moment go but wait a
moment can you explain the character
reasoning for this well they stop the
shooting stop or there's a moment
there's a something needs to be figured
out it's not just we'll get it done it
is we need to understand why this is
character driven we all focus on so much
of the stunts but what you don't see is
the sort of the the description of
reasoning and the dark plots and
character and we need to earn the
moments that you see